aux dernières nouvelles l'univers ne
serait âgé que de neuf ou dix milliards
d'années
cette nouvelle a laissé les astronomes
perplexe et ils se sont empressés de
construire de nouveaux télescopes qu'ils
pointent vers le ciel du pôle sud au
désert d'atacama
il faut trouver de nouveaux emplacements
pour des observatoires toujours plus
grands sur les sommets volcanique déjà
encombré des îles hawaïennes
cette course au télescope survient au
bon moment pour résoudre une nouvelle
énigme
les scientifiques s'accordaient pour
dire que l'univers était vieux d'environ
15 milliards d'années en 1994 de
nouvelles observations le rajeunit de 5
milliards d'années
mais comment est ce possible alors que
des étoiles beaucoup plus vieille ont
déjà été observés ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'homme a dû remettre
en question ses connaissances sur
l'univers
on
mon
les hindous avaient une vue naturaliste
de l'univers leur monde était porté par
quatre éléphantes les éléphants étaient
debout sur une tortue et la tortue nager
dans un océan de l'est
et un serpent géant entouré le tout
une image incroyable mais pas plus que
les théories et observation de la
cosmologie moderne il est difficile
d'admettre que l'univers est né d'un
grain minuscule pas plus grand qu'un
atome à partir d'un cataclysme que nous
avons baptisée le big bang
une explosion d'énergie brûlante qui
refroidit et se transforme en matière
d'ess ainsi que les choses ont commencé
et particules subatomiques s'assemblent
par la gravité
la formation d'atomes simple comme
l'hélium et l'oxygène
des boules d'hydrogène qui grossissent
et chauffe avec l'augmentation de leur
gravité
la naissance des étoiles
des amas de millions des toiles
des galaxy 2 milliards mes toiles
notre propre galaxie la voie lactée
contient 200 milliards des toiles et
parmi celles ci le soleil
une étoile née d'une boule de gaz qui
devient de plus en plus dense
quand la gravité augmente les
températures grimpent la fusion
nucléaire s'amorce et l'étoile commence
à briller
en une réaction nucléaire continue
l'étoile converti l'hydrogène en hélium
sa force de gravité et la seule chose
qui empêche une étoile d'exploser dans
l'espace
mais quand l'hydrogène diminue l'étoile
commence à grossir
elle change de couleur
et devient une géante rouge
quand l'hydrogène a disparu l'étoile
converti d'hélium en carbone puis en des
éléments plus lourds dans les plus
grosses étoiles quand le faire se
forment la gravité devient trop
importante et le choeur s'effondre les
toiles géantes explosent
c'est une supernova
riche en éléments plus lourds les débris
s'éparpillent dans la galaxie
un jour ils permettront la formation de
nouvelles étoiles
une telle explosion a pu déclencher la
naissance de notre étoile le soleil
entraînant l'effondrement d'un nuage de
poussière et de gaz
il y à plus de 5 milliards d'années la
nébuleuse condensé contient tout ce qui
va former le soleil les planètes et
notre terre
tandis que le nuage s'effondre sous la
force de la gravité la pression augmente
le centre devient de plus en plus chaud
quand la température devient critique
des réactions nucléaires surviennent et
le soleil est une étoile notre soleil
est trop petit pour fabriquer les
éléments les plus lourds donc le faire
indispensable à la vie de notre planète
doit être importé à partir des débris
d'une supernova
aujourd'hui le soleil a atteint son âge
mûr mais dans plus de 5 milliards
d'années sans l'hydrogène aura disparu
et notre étoile déclinera
mais d'abord il va grossir
il va devenir de plus en plus rouge est
de plus en plus gros
les planètes mercure et vénus seront
conçus mais les océans de la terre se
mettront à bouillir
quand le soleil sera devenue une géante
rouge il fera fondre les glaces de la
lointaine du temps
la vie pourrait alors se développer sur
ce satellite de saturne
mais le soleil ne vivra plus longtemps
son énergie épuisé il s'éteindra et se
re contractera lentement
notre étoile est devenu un cadavre d'une
naine blanche pas plus grande que la
terre
enveloppé dans un linceul de débris sol
est une nébuleuse planétaire
en étudiant la couleur et l'intensité de
la lumière des étoiles et comment elles
se regroupent entre elles les
scientifiques peuvent parvenir à une
compréhension de l'univers
voici les étoiles de oméga du centaure
elle forme un amas globulaires l'un des
nombreux qui se tiennent à l'extérieur
du bulbe central de la voie lactée
la lumière de ces étoiles révèlent leur
composition chimique
à partir de ces informations les
astronomes ont calculé que des amas
globulaires contiennent les étoiles les
plus anciennes de notre univers
et ces amas nous ont permis de connaître
notre place dans la voie lactée
le soleil est à la périphérie il se
trouve aux deux tiers du chemin allant
du centre de notre galaxie vers
l'extérieur
une galaxie comme la nôtre un grand
disque des toiles vue de côté la traînée
noir est composé de poussière d'où
naissent les étoiles les étoiles les
plus anciennes sont au centre les plus
vieilles de toute forme d'un halo autour
du centre ces amas globulaires
les étoiles les plus récentes sont dans
le contour bleus dans notre galaxie
la galaxie vu de dessous
une spirale céret de milliards des
toiles tout orbitant autour du centre
galactique
les objets qui tourne dans l'espace
produisent des couleurs c'est l'effet
doppler
quand on l'appliqué à une galaxie les
étoiles qui se dirige vers nous semble
bleus leur lumière et compresser la
lumière des étoiles qui s'éloigne été
tirés
c'est grâce à l'effet doppler que les
astronomes ont imaginé que les galaxies
tournent et dans le cas présent il faut
au soleil 250 millions d'années pour
faire un tour autour de leurs beats du
centre galactique
il existe des millions de galaxies
spirales comme notre voie lactée
le long des bras des nuages roses de
poussières et de gaz hydrogène où
naissent les étoiles
mais toutes les spirales ne sont pas
aussi serré voici une spirale part et le
centre est bien distinct des preuves
s'accumulent que notre galaxie est une
spirale barrée
certaines galaxies n'ont pas de formes
particulières les galaxies et régulières
comme celles ci ne semble pas donner
naissance à de nouvelles étoiles et
elles sont souvent petit
les plus grosses sont les galaxies
elliptiques
certaines ont la forme d'un ballon de
football d'autres d'un ballon de rugby
elles grossissent en dévorant les
galaxies plus petites qui s'approchent
trop près
ici nous voyons une galaxie spirale
avalé par une galaxie l'éthique du moins
selon une théorie
alpha du centaure est au coeur d'un
débat certains pensent que c'est une
galaxie unique
entouré d'un cercle de matière d'autres
pensent qu'il s'agit de deux galaxies
lier un ordinateur reproduit une version
les étoiles et les nuages de deux
galaxies fusionnent pour former une
seule entité
cette fusion est indiscutable voici les
antennes de la galaxie unicom deux
siamoises
en marche arrière sur un superordinateur
il y a des milliards d'années c'était
des galaxies séparer
personne ne sait laquelle mais l'une de
ces petites galaxies est passé à travers
une galaxie plus grosse une spirale
comme lorsqu'on lance à qaïm dans une
mare une vague de formation des toiles
se propage la grosse galaxie s'appelle
justement la roue de charrette
les superordinateurs multiplient la
puissance des télescopes pour l'étude
des galaxies
il ajoute les mathématiques de la
gravité du mouvement et de la masse aux
informations recueillies par
l'observation
les calculs démontrent que notre galaxie
a peut être fusionnée avec d'autres
aujourd'hui la voie lactée ressemble à
cela une galaxie indépendante
mais dans le ciel nocturne de
l'hémisphère sud et est visible à l'oeil
nu
il existe deux galaxie voisine de la
nôtre ce sont les nuages de magellan
observer de plus près les deux nuages
semblent perturber les astronomes
pensent que c'est dû à la proximité trop
grande de la voie lactée
celui ci le petit nuage de magellan
semble particulièrement troublé
et dans le grand nuage le contact avec
la voie lactée a pu déclencher la
naissance d'une profusion des toiles
les nuages de magellan sont beaucoup
plus petits que notre galaxie ce sont
des galaxies satellites de la voie
lactée dans des milliards d'années elle
se rapprocheront peut être à nouveau
au delà des nuages de magellan la
galaxie la plus proche et andromède dans
les années 20 sa distance avait été
calculée à 1 millions d'années lumière
aujourd'hui on pense qu'elle est trois
fois plus éloignée
c'est une indication de la marge
d'erreur qui existe dans les mesures du
cosmos mais comme ces images prises par
le télescope hubble
notre vision est de plus en plus clair
andromède à avaler au moins une autre
galaxie
malgré les grandes étendues vide
il n'est pas toujours facile d'avoir une
vision claire parfois une galaxie
bloquent la vue si elle est assez grande
elle agit comme une lentille déformante
et c'est comme cela que regardant à
travers une galaxie le télescope hubble
a vu un quasar distants comme une image
multiples
oui
depuis la découverte de cette technique
en 1912 les étoiles qui brillent
s'éteignent selon un cycle régulier ont
servi pour mesurer les distances dans le
cosmos ce sont des céphéides la période
de pulsations d'une cv id indique sa
véritable brillance sa luminosité
en chronométrant les variations de
brillance les astronomes détermine sa
luminosité plus la cpi d loin - et les
brillantes la différence entre la
brillance réel et apparente de l'acv ide
révèle à quelle distance elle se trouve
de la terre
les astronomes ont d'autres méthodes
pour calculer la distance il mesure la
luminosité damas des toiles
et de nébuleuses planétaires des anneaux
de fumée cosmique
les débris des toiles morte plus
important le flash d'une supernova
permet de calculer des distances 100
fois plus éloignée que celle d'une cv il
edwin hubble fut le premier à le dire
plus loin plus vite plus une galaxie est
loin plus elle recule vite plus sa
lumière s'étend dans le rouge
humble et l'astronome américain qui a
découvert en 1929 que l'univers était en
expansion
une preuve importante que tout a
commencé avec un big bang et se déplace
depuis vers l'extérieur
les quasars sont les objets les plus
distants que nous voyons dans l'univers
leurs lumières et la plus éloignée dans
le rouge ce sont d'intense concentration
d'énergie si brillante qu'elles sont
visibles de très loin des pulsars sont
peut être les coeurs des galaxies
lointaines
au centre de ces galaxies de gigantesque
trou noir libère des jets d'énergie
tandis qu'il dévore des étoiles
au début de 1994 le télescope hubble a
enregistré ce quasar distants de 12
milliards d'années lumière
il semble avaler une galaxie toute
entière
plus tard en 1994
hubble a observé la galaxie spirale m100
ce qu'il a vu à semer la confusion parmi
les astronomes
au coeur de m s'en bat les pulsations
d'une c'est fait
les astronomes en déduisent que m sans
n'est qu'à 50 millions d'années lumière
beaucoup plus près qu'il ne le pensait
oui
cette distance est la quantité de
lumière de la galaxie qui s'est décalé
vers le rouge suggère que l'expansion de
l'univers est deux fois plus rapide que
nous le pensions si cela est vrai
l'univers n'est âgé que de neuf ou dix
milliards d'années et non 15 comme nous
le pensions
oh
il est possible que le déplacement de m
sans dans l'espace soit accélérée par
des galaxies voisines seule
l'observation de ces fluides dans des
galaxies encore plus lointaine aideront
les astronomes à résoudre ce bébé
pourquoi une énigme parce que la chimie
des plus anciennes étoiles et amas
globulaires indiquent qu'ils sont âgés
de 13 à 15 milliards d'années
c'est trop vieux pour un univers qui est
né et à neuf milliards d'années
un univers plus jeunes ne permet pas une
évolution cosmique telle que nous la
connaissons
il ne donne pas aux anciennes super
étoile le temps de compléter leur cycle
de vie et de donner naissance à de
jeunes étoile comme le soleil
le dilemme de l'astronomie c'est que
même les mesures les plus modernes de
l'univers ont une marge d'erreur de 30%
afin de déterminer l'âge de l'univers
les observateurs doivent estimer la
distance du nombre le plus grand de
galaxies et en utilisant autant de
moyens que possible ils doivent bâtir
une image tridimensionnelle de l'univers
c'est une tâche immense car il ya des
milliards de galaxies ici au télescope
schmidt en australie les scientifiques
ont accéléré le travail en calibrant la
position des capteurs optiques à partir
d'une photo d'une lointaine région du
cosmos
ils sont fixés sur des endroits où des
galaxies ont été enregistrés sur la
photo d'origine
chaque capteur détecteur à la brillance
et les couleurs d'une galaxie
particulière
le calibrage est alors chargé dans le
télescope qui a servi à prendre la photo
d'origine
le télescope est pointée exactement vers
le secteur du ciel qui a été
photographiée
la précision est d'une importance vitale
chaque capteur doit capter uniquement la
lumière de la galaxie qui lui est
assignée
la lumière de centaines de galaxies est
enregistrée en une seule exposition
un travail qui prenait auparavant des
mois
la distance et le décalage vers le rouge
de chaque galaxie sont enregistrés dans
un ordinateur il les reproduit comme un
segment de l'univers une tranche de
temps et des espaces
un morceau du puzzle cosmique
lentement morceau par morceau
une image globale apparaît
nous savons déjà que des milliards de
galaxies sont enfilés comme des perles
de fumer à travers les vitres de
l'univers mais ne savons pas pourquoi
des télescopes de plus en plus
sophistiqués seront capables de fouiller
plus loin dans l'espace et dans le passé
se télescopent o'shea sera le plus grand
télescope au monde
il se compose de quatre instruments
optiques formant un oeil unique de plus
de 15 mètres de diamètre braqués sur le
cosmos
il permettra peut-être de déterminer
l'âge de l'univers mais il ne verra pas
le big bang l'univers avait au moins
trois cent mille ans avant qu'ils ne
deviennent transparents et que les
premiers rayons lumineux ne puisse
voyager à travers l'espace
mais il y à d'autres moyens de détecter
l'aube de l'univers les rayonnements
micron du fond cosmique sont un écho du
big bang lui même le vaisseau spatial
kobe a découvert des irrégularités dans
le fond micro ondes qui pourraient être
les graines de la structure de l'univers
à sa naissance et au pôle sud
des astronomes viennent étudier le
cosmos primitif dans l'infrarouge proche
voici un télescope infrarouge ils
marchent merveilleusement bien ici car
l'atmosphère y est clair et sèche la
vapeur d'eau absorbe l'infrarouge au
pôle sud
l'humidité est gelé en permanence
c'est ici que les observateurs collecte
les données infrarouges venant de
l'espace ils espèrent ainsi avoir la
preuve des premiers signes de la
structure cosmique
tout de suite après le big bang
quelle que soit l'origine du big bang
les scientifiques pensent qu'un grain
pas plus grand qu'un atome a donné
naissance à la matière et de cette
matière est née une abondance des toiles
des étoiles qui ont brillé et exploser
des étoiles qui ont semé les éléments de
la vie dans l'univers des étoiles qui se
sont rassemblés en galaxie des étoiles
qui ont donné naissance aux planètes et
sur l'une de ces planètes des créatures
ont évolué qui tente aujourd'hui de
savoir comment tout cela a commencé